it's time once again for God's
everywhere to quake in their mighty
celestial booths Kratos is back for a
new dition of God of War
everyone's favorite shaven-headed deity
demolisher has returned for a new
adventure taking place many years after
the end of the third game during this
time that goes to Sparta has been busy
relocating his life to Scandinavia in
search of a new beginning
but how has he changed and what awaits
the player in this new nordic adventure
welcome to the world of norse mythology
it's a stark contrast from the ancient
greek setting with trees snow and ruin
carved stone dominating the landscape
perhaps the biggest evolution to be
found though is within Kratos himself
chief among these developments is
something that will certainly impact the
gameplay experience for the player and
Kratos his own emotional journey
throughout the game that's right
Kratos now has a giant beard also a Sun
that's probably more important enter at
Reyes raising the boy has clearly made
an impact on Kratos his personality and
their father-son relationship is the
core building block for the whole new
narrative he is no longer the embodiment
of rage and vengeance in the gameplay
revealed so far we clearly see a more
mature side of the immortal God
nurturing his son teaching him how to
hunt how to fight and the art of tough
love do not be sorry be better we may
also see at Reyes doing his share of
teaching in return in the sections of
gameplay revealed so far we see him
becoming a calming perhaps even rational
influence on his father bestowing advice
which he received from his recently
deceased mother in fact a Tracy's
mother's death appears to be the
catalyst for the game's narrative as the
journey begins with the quest to fulfill
her final wish to take her ashes to a
resting place atop the highest peak in
all the Norse realms this weighty
narrative is in keeping with the broader
total shift in the series and this new
God of War journey promises a more
emotional story than we've seen before
combined with challenging puzzles and a
whole load of intense combat
and speaking of combat like its
predecessors fighting is still front and
center in the new god of war although
like Kratos it has evolved battles are
still vicious and brutal but they take
on a more deliberate an impactful style
complete with satisfying spurts of lava
from Norse foes in a fights the
father-son duo team up with Kratos
taking on the lion's share of the
bitchery and at Reyes providing critical
strategic combat supports with well
placed arrows capable of stunning
enemies amongst his other acrobatic
moves this however is not the limit of
the boys abilities having a God for dad
will do that at Reyes has powers of his
own but they appear to be couched in
empathy rather than violence the
youngster is capable of sensing the
thoughts and feelings of creatures
throughout the landscape he can read the
runic language of the world around them
and can even decipher the intentions of
gigantic sea monsters I really hope he's
got that one right don't think our
father-son duo will be talking their way
out of every epic encounter though the
venture looks set to thrust the pair
against a host of angry Nordic enemies
and with the rich tapestry of Norse
mythology to call upon this game
promises to feature battles like nothing
we've seen before in God of War all that
said can Kratos truly escape his past
how will a trace respond when he learns
of his godly origins not to mention his
father's destructive history wherever
the story goes their God of War is
shaping up to be a unique adventure
combining the series staples with a new
relatable and ultimately human story
should we be preparing to shed tears as
much as lava blood only time will tell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]